and domican sue has been one of the most
feared defenders in the nfl since the
moment he came into the league
when i'm on the football field i'm in
between those white lines my job is to
piss everybody off and so if i don't do
that i'm not doing my job
at six foot four inches and more than
300 pounds ndamukong soo has done his
job in the nfl for 12 years now
sometimes
maybe too well he got you know frozen
feet and didn't realize he was stepping
on my calf he also stomped on one of my
teammates at one point he's been
you know in my time one of the most
dominant three techniques in the game
i understand not everybody's gonna like
me and that's okay but i guarantee the
people that don't like me don't know who
i am and haven't even taken the time to
get to know me
after spending a few days with the
domicant here in the rainy city of
portland i've gotten an insight into a
soft-spoken native portlandian family
man restaurant tour and real estate
investor who's endeavoring to have more
impact with his businesses than he's had
against quarterbacks in the nfl
it's a simple concept of like i don't
want to be at the top of the pyramid or
be amongst the one percent and be there
by myself i want to bring other people
with me that are like-minded and you
want to work with them and when you have
the opportunity to help other people at
the same time it's a smart business
decision
why not create both
dunk
[Music]
say hello
[Music]
right into it right away
they don't go anywhere without each
other a few times that they have they're
trying to figure out where the other one
is and i have twin sisters and i have
twin cousins twins definitely running
the family she has twins on her side too
for someone who is so single-minded on
the field seeing sue in his native
habitat it's a bit startling and not
just because he's a dad
from his home office bouncing from zooms
to calls to texts he's methodically
creating an empire
it includes investments in tech
companies like quip and ember and
hospitality investments including
restaurants in portland and beyond
but the primary focus for sue has been
real estate over the past decade much of
his investments have been focused on
multi-family and commercial projects
so tell me your business philosophy like
in a nutshell like how do you distill it
down just understanding that investing
and social impact can go without
question hand in hand and i think you
can
impact other people's lives and do good
but at the same time make smart business
decisions where it's i've always seen it
as a true give and take relationship
versus just someone always taking and i
think that's what that capitalistic
mindset that majority of america lives
in
[Music]
it's a short trip from where we're
sitting to see where sue came from his
home in the offseason is here in the
irvington district of portland and his
house is only a few streets away from
where he grew up
this hoop has been here for ages oh my
gosh and
the family that owned this house their
son actually played in the nba there
used to be at the far end we called our
little hoop where we'd have our main
duck contest what was portland like like
when you were growing up i mean now it's
seen as this like boom town right but
was it like that 20 years ago no
portland was very very small everybody
knew everybody pretty much
growing up in portland sue was
surrounded by sports nike's headquarters
was just 20 minutes away and he still
works out there when he's home his older
sister in gumsu also became an elite
athlete she'd end up going to the 2004
olympics as a soccer player playing for
their father's home country of cameroon
often times in a family especially when
you have multiple superstars it's clear
that like this family is in the business
of growing superstar athlete my parents
could care less about they wanted us to
be in athletics and have that
fulfillment of being in sports
but
hands down education was the number one
and my sister's super smart she got a
degree in kinesiology and biological
sciences
sue's parents divorced when he was two
but stayed close his mom was an
elementary school teacher and his dad
owned an hvac company as a young kid i
enjoyed
going to work with him i got to spend a
lot of time with my dad
on job sites and it's really what got me
into the business
as i got a little bit older towards
middle school it would be me going to
the job site and being able to say
you can earn
five ten dollars
towards your bike
he just wanted to see if i'd be willing
to get up at six o'clock in the morning
this was my dad's house that we grew up
in we bought the building
lived on one side and rented the other
side and that's where we really started
to learn about real estate or how i
started to learn about real estate
from those early days sue's fascination
with and ambition in real estate only
grew
especially as a pro football career gave
him the means to eye bigger and bigger
projects he's been buying and building
property in his hometown of portland as
well as across the united states
including luxury residential office and
hospitality space and affordable housing
all with a mission to help build
generational wealth through real estate
and real estate is one of the most tried
and true places to store and grow wealth
buying and owning property commercial or
residential when done right can be a
source of income as well as a crew value
over time that's if you choose projects
wisely and have patience over the past
few years the pandemic both increased
demand and lowered the supply of housing
leading to skyrocketing values at the
same time
low interest rates made acquiring the
capital needed to purchase properties
even easier
more recently though
rising mortgage rates and new supply
have begun to change that picture and
rents have been increasing at historic
levels
owning real estate has the additional
benefit of influencing maybe even
transforming the neighborhood and the
community around you that's an idea
passed down to sue from his father
[Applause]
he assembled a handful of different lots
and projects and this is one of them
that has been i won't say a unicorn but
it's been very very profitable
if you look at the building we have the
exterior so we gutted everything inside
and kept the exterior facade and then
built on top of that
it was originally a chop shop when we
first took over
people at night when i was growing up in
the 90s and early 2000s would not walk
up and down these streets by any means
and you see it's live you got great
restaurants up and down
coffee shops further down you got
everybody probably knows of salt and
straw they're right up the street
there's no way they would be here back
in the 90s so my dad had a great vision
and focus for seeing where the city was
moving
athletes investing in real estate
properties in order to renovate them
isn't that remarkable at its face
what separates sue is his fluency in the
details of the business
he learned that on the job with his dad
as well as in the classroom
account for him
plan for him
recognize him as perhaps the most
disruptive defensive player in college
football he's the most dominant player
that i've seen this season a heavily
recruited athlete he opted for the
university of nebraska which has not
only a great football team but a highly
regarded construction engineering
program
i knew
leaving high school i wanted to get in
get an engineering degree because my
ultimate goal was to come back here to
portland and build another division to
my dad's company
granted that didn't necessarily happen
because other things transpired
but like going bro yeah like going pro
yeah
i think i get it from both my parents
but primarily my dad we've always been
somewhat calculated and focused on what
we want to accomplish in building and
connecting with the right people and
then also just learning from others
lincoln nebraska may not be the first
place you'd think to meet some of the
world's most influential business people
the portland metro area alone has more
people living in it than the entire
state of nebraska
but his play on the field allowed him to
meet and maintain relationships with
future mentors in his business career
including the oracle of omaha himself
warren buffett
i loved the wall street journal story
last year that called you a secret
finance nerd um
let's talk a little bit about that
because this guy's remarkable yeah
ever since then
we've been
close friends confidant and really a
true mentor being able to bounce a bunch
of different ideas off and then also
understand how he envisions the world
although he's not fully into real estate
and he's changed a little bit because he
now has berkshire hathaway homes and
whatnot
[Music]
that long-term vision and that being
able to buy and hold is
one of the greatest things ever that i
learned from him
sue also met with one of the most
interesting people who has split time
between the locker room and the
boardroom jomoglia
mowglia's career began in the coaching
world but he would rise through the
ranks to lead td ameritrade as ceo from
2001 to 2008 and chairman from 2008 to
2020
navigating the company through the
global financial crisis and its
aftermath as well as its eventual
combination with schwab
he was around my entire senior year and
one day i just asked him it's like you
always leave every friday before our
games and come back saturday's ready to
go like where do you go and it's always
like a black car going out it's like i
go to new york go take care of business
with td ameritrade i'm the chairman
there and then i come back and obviously
have my role here with you guys and i
was like wow that's pretty interesting
like i'd love to learn more and so he
said well make sure you follow up with
me after the season
all right so
i asked him this exact same question
check out what joe had to say
so our first step
our first step is going to be i want you
to come down to my office uh the season
was over and i want to see the budget
that you would put together
so he comes down he's about a month
later and i got to tell you i was
impressed he comes into my office with a
suit on tie on he looked great
and we sat down he showed me his budget
the budget was about 60 000 now now
we've talked about that a little bit in
two or three months
he was going to get a pretty significant
contract and he was going to make a
shitload of money
and sixty thousand dollar budget with
regards to all the different things that
people is going to be interacting with
it's probably not going to quite quite
work out yeah that's exactly right
he uh he's like man you're going to be
spending anywhere from twenty thirty
thousand dollars a month and i was like
there's no way i'm in college right now
my rent's like fifteen hundred yeah i
didn't imagine ever getting there long
before i'm there so
there was of course one other pivotal
person he'd meet and cultivate a
relationship with during his college
days his future wife katya i have only
been a champion with this beautiful
lady in my life we met all the way back
in 2009 i was a women's basketball
player and he was a football player and
the best way that i like to explain it
is
he
ran after me a lot and would always try
to kind of say he's going to break my
ankles or what are we going to play
one-on-one and i was like uh hi who are
you
and so after
some time i finally gave him a little a
little chance and i got to know him and
truly he became my best friend
the two have had a whirlwind past few
years they moved in together in 2018
were engaged in 2019 and had their then
traditional zoom wedding back in 2020 in
february of 2021 endowment would win his
first super bowl with the tampa bay
buccaneers and just a few months later
the two would welcome their twin sons
kari and kingston
when the two aren't changing diapers or
doing the latest tick-tock trend they're
business partners working together out
of the same home office for much of the
off-season we really both listen to each
other's calls we kind of have what's
going on in the mornings um after
workouts and when the boys are during
breakfast we'll be like what's your plan
for today how many calls do you have
when are your calls are the ones that i
can listen in on are the ones that he's
like you know what i wanna i wanna be a
part of that i wanna to
participate or just listen in the two
also work together on the sioux family
foundation the charitable arm of sue's
business ventures that focuses on
empowering people with resources for
long-term success
one issue they're working to address is
financial literacy
right now there is no financial literacy
requirement at all at any level and to
me that's mind-blowing it finances are
in our life from the minute we are born
to the minute we are no longer here and
so to not have a requirement of how
things
run how to properly use your finances
is in is to me quite insane
we have specific programs that we work
with that students that are coming from
all different types of backgrounds are
able to come together and really
learn
how that's structured right now we're
focused on our own backyard which would
be portland oregon the ultimate goal
would be to be in every state
and while many athletes give back to
their community the zoos extend that
notion to all of their business
enterprises as well
looking not only at how they can impact
the bottom line but impact their
communities and one of those spaces has
been restaurants
[Music]
hi
one of sue's restaurant investments is
here in downtown portland a fast casual
restaurant called bay's fried chicken he
started with a previously successful
portland-based restaurant tour named
micah camden
to understand it i ordered a chicken
sandwich for myself
for journalism
tell me about where we are
we are in downtown portland this
building was built in 1882 so that's an
old building you don't get much older
than that in portland we got the fried
chicken sandwich we got the chicken
strips it's easy it's approachable it's
super great quality when we open this up
we went straight organic on all the
chicken which was awesome it's very very
juicy so be careful
but good food and a good location aren't
guarantees of success in the restaurant
world
restaurants are tricky businesses for
athletes seemingly easy to understand
but complex to conceive operate and
market actually they're hard businesses
for anyone even food pros
while micah himself has had successful
ventures with restaurants like boxer
ramen little big burger and blue star
donuts in 2016 he had to shut down a
previous attempt at a fried chicken
restaurant
restaurants are high risk what's
appealing to you about being in this
particular restaurant business this one
this is a foodie town i got amazing
chefs people that enjoy quality high
quality food and kind of giving back to
my community something that was missing
and then also you come out and see
they're in a pandemic a lot of people
are supporting people in their endeavors
and seeing the success that they're
doing and want to support people when
they're sometimes in the rough spots or
even when they're at their heights the
last few years have been far from the
salad days for the restaurant industry
the pandemic altered dining living and
working habits and everything from
lockdowns to labor shortages have
plagued the food business
bays opened this location only a few
months before the global pandemic shut
down much of the country and george
floyd's murder led to a reckoning around
racial inequality as protests and
counter-protests swept the country
portland became a focal point
images of property destruction by
protesters who themselves were often the
victims of violent attacks by extreme
right-wing groups as well as portland
police ricocheted across social media
giving rise to a flood of disinformation
by opponents of police reform this was
ground zero right out our front doors
ground zero for the nightly protest that
went on for three or four months
thankfully enough this community knew
that this this location was owned by
sioux and then we didn't get stuff
thrown to our windows
you know stuff like that but the
attention that was brought to portland
via those protests it hit its cause it
hit its nerve and it started the
conversation that is still going on
today
portland has in recent years been an
almost cartoonish example of a liberal
stronghold
and while coffee shops and breweries are
a thing here the real portland is a
complicated place in a state of near
existential crisis facing issues around
affordability the unhoused and crime
people of color in portland have been
historically disenfranchised especially
when it comes to one of sue's biggest
businesses real estate and development
like in many cities across the u.s
nearly a century ago redlining practices
allowed white neighborhoods easier
access to capital and excluded black in
immigrant communities including sue's
home in the northeast of portland where
irvington was quote still desirable just
a few blocks north alberta was
considered quote hazardous and while
redlining was made illegal in the 60s
its effects are still being felt
investment in areas like alberta where
su and his father bought a property have
helped revitalize neighborhoods but it's
also led to gentrification driving up
home prices and pushing people of color
out
through his development company hms sue
is hoping to change the traditional
narrative
we are down on alberta further down from
where we're at before but this is 30th
where
we are creating alberta alley which is
going to be
a nice collection of bipark type of
restaurants
beyond creating a space for black
indigenous and people of color owners of
restaurants sue has also brought in more
black investors including another pro
football player with portland roots
named brennan scarlet we went to take a
look but as you might expect
we had to go inside let's go inside and
then we've got our portland bad weather
and get out of this portland rain right
now alberta alley is still very much a
work in progress but the intention is to
create a space for multiple restaurants
and eateries in a communal well alley
type experience currently they're
working to bring a latino owned
expansion of puppies chulos and another
bay's fried chicken location to the
space
you guys are native sons you know sort
of putting a different mark on
this city
tell me about you know your process of
being an owner and not just a like
participant or not just a customer to to
something yeah portland's uh an
interesting place and has a long history
of racism
of
marginalizing certain groups like the
house that i grew up in on the deed it
says that a black person can own that
house right but my dad you know
purchased that house back you know in
the 90s right now you think about like
purchasing commercial properties like
this right under black ownership and
then also you know the cycle of having
tenants here and and being intentional
about having tenants here that are
represented that may have historically
not had been able to have an opportunity
to be represented
when i grew up here it was predominantly
a black neighborhood and a lot of
different people
just kind of starting out their
businesses here that really in the
bypass space and so a lot of
gentrification moved those things out
and brought up new developments and not
really looking for a way to bring those
people back in and so this is an
interesting way to fold them back into
having that opportunity of kind of
getting kicked out and now now coming
back and hopefully being successful and
finding ways to help them be successful
we have a very altruistic
view when it comes to our real estate
endeavors and have multi-family units
and be able to create them
in mixed-use developments i think one of
the most things i'm going to be proud of
as we're getting this journey
and started is our ally project
attainable living initiative where we
really want to have the ability to
afford attainable living for everybody
and we're starting here in portland
there's never been a greater need for
housing and yet
it's almost impossible to get housing
done and developed
sue's partner at hms is joel anderson a
third generation contractor and
developer based in portland and while
the two have developed a portfolio of
everything from high-rise residential to
industrial one of the common threads is
their vision of the social impact real
estate can have
both sue and i have been very fortunate
and worked very hard some lucky bounces
that went our way and there's a whole
bunch of people that we interact with in
our communities that just didn't have
the same opportunities and have never
had access to invest in commercial real
estate
while real estate investments have been
a great place to store wealth the recent
housing market has left many unable to
participate
especially when it comes to bipod
communities
and i think one of the ways that we can
do that with uh with alt cap as we call
it is giving them the opportunity to not
only pay rent and understand those
different pieces and keep it afloat but
also give them an opportunity to be a
part of it and one thing you know about
people when they have ownership into
a building they take care of it that
much more better
affordable housing which about half of
americans say their community lacks
is a hot button issue long freighted
with racism some say they oppose it over
perceived increases in crime erosion in
the tax base and increased traffic
sue and joel believe they can ultimately
flip the script by better knitting
residents into the community
economically by affording everyone a
stake altruistic capital
alt cap
its very intention is to bring people in
that have been excluded if we take an
accredited investor somebody and say
okay you're gonna invest a hundred
thousand dollars in this project they go
yes we go but you're only getting credit
for 95 of that and five thousand dollars
or five percent of your investment is
going to go to a non-profit
all cap community reinvestment fund and
we say to them now okay you can
participate from 500 to 5 000 dollars
and for every dollar you invest we will
match you through the alt cap
reinvestment fund dollar for dollar and
so if you have somebody who invests 500
they now have a thousand dollar
investment into this project they've
effectively doubled their return it may
seem complicated but joel and sue
believe that programs like alt cap can
give people who've long been excluded
from real estate an attainable
investment option while some investors
might back at giving up some of their
economics proponents of this shared
ownership believe it's long overdue
if we can get real estate transactions
to include everybody
you're talking about trillion dollar
industry
that has the ability to engage everybody
in a micro fashion earned at a
disproportionate rate you can transition
the wealth of our country in short order
[Music]
of course undoing centuries of economic
disparity and systemic financial bias
that's a long game
for sue it's his life's work and he'll
be able to devote even more time to it
once he leaves the game of football
when you leave the league how do you
think about the idea of transition
especially given
everything that you've already done in
business yeah the transition's a
difficult one for me uh i look at it
consistent and have over the last couple
years from a standpoint especially since
the boys came into my life if i want to
spend as much time with them and not
miss out on things
how do you balance like the economics
versus the emotions i mean this is a
deep analysis this is one of the most
important decisions you'll ever make i
think the analysis is very
straightforward it comes down to numbers
in a lot of ways but then also just do i
believe i have more to offer without
question and do i aspire to be in the
hall of fame no question do i want to do
that at the cost of not spending time
with my kids not being around my family
timing is always going to be
key to that we've got a good process
with me and the wife i lean on her a lot
and i think she has a good telltale to
give me some different things to think
about and she always says it's
ultimately your decision but i
truthfully knows both of our decisions
[Music]
you